le verdict est tombé ce matin la filiale
française d'ikea était condamné pour
avoir espionné ses salariés direction
versailles où nous retrouvons notre
reporter mohamud alors mona bonjour vous
êtes devant le tribunal de versailles
ik le géant du meuble suédois a été
reconnu coupable en effet après des mois
d'attentes le verdict est tombé et
l'amendé plutôt salée pour ikea
le géant de l'ameublement suédois est
condamné à un million d'euros d'amendé
un des ex pdg de la société jean louis
baillot à lui été condamné à deux ans de
prison avec sursis pour avoir espionné
ses salariés entre 2009 et à 2012 la
peine est bien plus clémente que celle
qu'avait demandé la procureure qui était
est d'un an ferme
jean-françois paris l'ancien monsieur
sécurité d'ikea france qui avait reconnu
les contrôles de masse de ses employés a
été condamné lui à 18 mois
d'emprisonnement et il doit être dix
mille euros damende une dizaine d'autres
prévenus étaient également concernés par
ce français
le tribunal correctionnel de versailles
les a reconnus coupables de recel à de
données à caractère personnel par un
moyen frauduleux dans cette affaire dite
d'espionnage puisque c'est ainsi qu'elle
a été renommé elle a été très médiatisé
son vent parties civiles se sont
constituées il demandait tous un
jugement exemplaire
pour rappel ikea avait comparu en mars
dernier pour avoir mis en place un
fichage illégal d'une centaine de
salariés à l'aide d'une société de
surveillance privée qui leur
fournissaient des informations
confidentielles comme les antécédents
judiciaires ou encore lé patrimoine des
intéressés
pamela tabardel est la procureur l'a
répété je cite c'est un message fort
qu'il faut envoyer à toutes les sociétés
commerciales
l'enjeu de ce procès et la protection de
nos vies privées
on a un mode alors en direct du tribunal
de versailles merci pour toutes ces
précisions